si bruno et camionneurs olivier
présentateur et daniel entraîneur quelle
est la profession de quentin 15 secondes
fait quoi quand un dans la vie quentin
et quant à par quentin du groupe alliage
quant à quentin c'est logique
ah oui c'est mais il faut faire un petit
alors un petit truc je vous expliquerai
tout s'est ensuite bien entendu unanime
sai répondu à beinheim way hassan
benaddi il fait quoi quand un gmi foire
je crois pourquoi il est fois j'essayais
avec les l'alphabet et bah justement
c'est la bonne c'est la bonne piste mais
vous êtes mauvais qu'est-ce que vous
avez mis de lambeaux gmi patineurs
patineurs ouais kelly vdev ni fourrure
daniel moreau hamner ramoneur pour vous
les ramoneurs j'aimais bien mais j'ai
rien compris je sais où je mets mon lit
j'avais juste tuerie ramoneur monsieur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
façon elle voulait fouras elle était
très fatiguée mais le célèbre monsieur
qui soit pour eux le ramoneur ça me va
très bien
jean michel maire vous aimez quoi baj
émirats bonheur bah bien sûr parce que
c'est la bonne
le métier c'est la lettre qui suit le
prénom pc op des oeufs
après plus exactement potasse et mon
mental
r b c d e f g h i j k l amène au pq est
arrivé et donc
[Rires]
et ramon
après le cul il ya le r et voilà donc
ramoneur neurologique un mois six mois
une autre usine ça n'a aucune autre
piste mais ma logique hein alors si
j'étais vous votre logique c'est qui
c'est quoi votre il avoue oui alors
pourquoi ces oublis déménageurs en
fonction des syllabes regard des
camionneurs présentateur daniela 4 après
trois et ensuite quatre noms des ménages
renault qui n'a rien à voir de quoi si
la carrière que de fil on a déjà entendu
ces mots si je pense que ça nous a fait
du bien ça va ça détend louis